[Music]
it's the dday anniversary I have to get
to French I'd love you had a go Hardy
but we have a responsibility of care to
you sounds like you have me dead and
buried
already Jesus where did you come from
don't stand there walk come on
go War veteran escapes old folks on meet
his army buddies in France the last
Rifleman people will love
it it is a miracle that you made it this
far you are quite the soldier Mr
Kfar look that's me 17 years out of date
sir we all have our expiry dates I'm 92
and 3/4 years old well pass my expiry
deal it's an up BL smuggling soldiers
us three musketeers all for one and one
for all ehy that's the thing about folks
like us Ary we're all living with
ghosts hey you want to pick out someone
none of us can ever forget but maybe we
can forgive
[Music]
him how in the name of God do you think
you're going to get to Normandy so you
can't even find the bathroom in your own
it's very funny